author columnist mark Stein was also
watching last night and joins us so mark
you got a say of the Hollywood people I
mean they do care deeply wouldn't you
say much more deeply than than a person
like you cares yeah they they do they
care and that was the message they cared
that that guy you had on now saying that
movies give a voice to the voiceless I
have to laugh they did that all day long
they say movies give a voice to the
voiceless shortly before they cut off
the microphone of the best sound editing
guy because his co-winner has gone long
and her speech so it was critical as we
watch you know Lisa said she just wanted
to have fun you mentioned a few a few
decades ago the Oscar shows were a big
deal and they were conventional shows of
that type they've gotten rid of
everything they've gotten rid of the
song-and-dance they've gotten rid of the
jokes they've gotten rid of the hosts
they got rid of the gowns their gowns
were frumpy last night except for Billy
Porter in that what did he call it a a
tuxedo dress that was the only time I
felt the rustle of taffeta so he was the
only one I would have asked to dance
without the post Oscar ball they got rid
of the thank yous to Harvey Weinstein
which constituted 40% of the Oscar time
of the last 20 years and all that left
was this pious honest virtue signaling
which I think they they think because
they bought and out and they got a
little bit of an uptick of an audience
that in fact they now have a core
audience that actually doesn't want fun
to go back to Lisa's word that it's just
much more comfortable with the pious
earnest boring virtue signaling and is
an is happy just to stick with that for
its own sake because for some reason I
wonder it makes them feel good do they I
mean Hollywood in some ways is over its
diminishing in its power and it's
reached the technology's been surpassed
by others but I wonder if they're kind
of just going through the motions like
this is what you have to say if you're a
director and actor ya have to make these
noises
do you think they still believe them
well I think Spike Lee certainly does he
he walked out because whatever it's
called green room green door whatever it
is green room won the Best Picture I
think he does actually mean it I think
most of the other people reading
glassy-eyed from the teleprompter one
thing is fascinating to be the world's
greatest actors and actresses they can
play any role on the planet but they
can't read a dull telly prompted lead
and piece of prose about giving voice to
the voiceless and put any life into it
they're just awful prompter readers you
would clean up at the Oscars for Best
prompter reader Tucker way ahead of
Julia Roberts or any of these other
stars they just can't do it and so I
think they are just going through the
motions and they're doing it because
this is just part of what it means to be
in it 20 years ago you had to give
Harvey Weinstein a back rub when he
asked you up to his hotel room now you
just have to genuflect to transgender
rights or whatever is this year's
fashion they're just doing what they
need to do to keep themselves in work
did anybody say anything artistic which
is to say unexpected interesting against
the grain radical or was it all just
approved thoughts no it was approved
thoughts and again to go back to Lisa's
word fun what was interesting to me was
that there was no witch or charm or even
any sense of joy or pleasure in the
event that was what was that was what
was palpable almost even when you listen
to someone like Spike Lee you sort of
sense the grievance a guy whose work
getting a statuette for making a movie
and he somehow feels obliged to talk
about America's genocide of its native
people is sort of ugly trivia if you
seriously believe it's genocide it's
actually trivializing of that to connect
it to you getting some crummy award for
Best Adapted Screenplay I don't think
there's anything serious
it's about this they've they've taken
out all the joy or the charm or the wit
all the fun and they haven't found
anything to put in its place
Wow I don't need the they've lost the
power even to offend me that's a Down
chuckle I I should do eight bars of
hooray for Hollywood like the old days
we don't Mark Steyn great to see you
thank you thanks